Jon jones.
First heavyweight fight.
Brock Lesnar,
bom,
Bom,
bom.
Yeah.
Imagine that fight the only problem.
Did you think so?
Yes.
I think you're just completely
died in fucking steel.
Brick would fucking ratchet pissed.
Pissed that go off in Cleveland and
he'll fuck Brock Lesnar because it'll say
it.
You better do the fucking steroids.
Feel pick is crazy,
mother fucker.
Yo Yo chick.
I love him.
I love him to immigrant mentality.
Bring him on.
Give him more fucking steroid.
What's that you another?
Yeah,
whatever the fuck.
He definitely born in Cleveland,
Ohio,
but when it's got that
fucking crazy blood in them,
put him in there with a guide.
I know.
Fuck my car.
Oh No.
I think Steve Bay beach.
You know what the biggest
embarrassment log?
That would be a crazy,
the biggest fucking embarrassment of
the year that brought was embarrassing.
It's just embarrassing.
I,
it's Mark Hunt.
They put him in there with a guy
that's coming off rocket fucking fuel.
That dude don't jumped on the ball.
What is the size of his fucking head?
He's taking shit that makes
your fucking head grow.
Get the fucking pit bulls.
I hope they put them against my yo.
Check.
I will fly to fucking
clean back damage climate.
Amen.
I found the snot in my nose.
It was bigger than this gum.
The aid that I take the gum out to eat.
It
was so long.
It was like a cook book.
I got a flashback from the
hell that motherfucker anyway.
Oh booger.
Cause I love him.
I love him.
From time to time I have a little pimple
and it's got like a little clam board
with you with all this shit from time to
time.
Oh,
when you eat,
when you do code for 30 years,
it's a habit.
You wake up in the morning,
pick one out.
It's like candy cane with coke gossip.
You inhale that motherfucker.
It's like going to the dentist for free.
I will throw up on this fucking table.
Do you ever do feel like his
boogers and you know what man?
Go ahead.
Keep doing those steroids.
Put them in there against
Cleveland motherfucker.
Dude,
kill him.